welcome everyone to this panel
discussion on fixing a broken global
order is it too late
co-sponsored by the Macmillan Center for
International and area studies and the
local program committee of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and we want
to thank both the Macmillan Center and
the American Academy for helping arrange
this event all of you are invited after
the event to a reception upstairs on the
second floor we're fortunate to have
such a distinguished group of panelists
each of whom will speak for about seven
minutes before we open the floor for
discussion and I just want all of you to
know that this is being recorded so you
will be part of the public discussion
should you choose to participate and
this will be on the web page of the
Macmillan Center and also on the
American Academy so I'm going to
introduce very briefly the panelists
we're going more or less in alphabetical
order and then we'll we'll get on with
it
so first is Sam Gordon the James burrow
Moffat professor of economics who is an
authority on economic growth innovation
technology diffusion and firm dynamics
in 2004 he and Jonathan Eaton received
the Frisch medal for their paper
technology geography and trade published
in econometrics in 2018 they shared the
onassis Prize in international trade
he's a fellow of the econometrics
Society member of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences and research
associate at the National Bureau of
Economic Research Paul Kennedy is the J
Richardson Dilbert professor of history
and director of the maritime and Naval
Studies program at Yale he's the author
of at last count 19 books including the
rise and fall of the great powers and
preparing for the 21st century to name
just two he's a world-renowned authority
on our
topic of the day and is a fellow of the
Royal Historical Society the American
Philosophical Society the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences the British
Academy and in 2000 was made commander
of the Order of the British Empire for
services to the discipline of history
ian shapiro sterling professor of
political science at yale is an
authority on democracy justice and
methods of social inquiry he's the
author of many books including a
forthcoming book with michael gratz the
wolf at the door which makes a case for
domestic compensation to losers in the
world economy as a way to stabilize
global economic integration and
prosperity about which i'm sure he will
be speaking with us this evening we
expect that another book will soon
follow coming out of the devayne
lectures which he is currently offering
at yale on the subject of politics in
today's world Jean su the John MSHA
professor of modern Chinese studies in
comparative literature at Yale and chair
of the Council on East Asian Studies is
also the author of numerous books
including most recently a book about how
China entered the IT era the kingdom of
characters : language Wars and China's
rise to global power she's received
fellowships and honors from the Society
of fellows at Harvard Woodrow Wilson
Foundation Center for Advanced studying
the behavioral sciences at Stanford the
Alexander von Humboldt foundation
Radcliffe Institute for Advanced Studies
New Directions fellowship from the
mellon foundation and most recently the
John Simon Guggenheim Foundation
professor arnhem Westat is a
world-renowned scholar of global history
he's the author of many books including
one on China's international history
since 1750 and most recently a book
entitled the cold war a world history
it's a book of power and breadth on the
origins conduct and results of the Cold
War in this book I can tell you
available on Amazon's audible books I
couldn't put it down
he's now writing about China's late 20th
century integration into the world
economy he's a member of the British
Academy among others and Yale is very
fortunate to have recently wooed him I
don't want to say stolen him
Harvard University so join me in
greeting our panelists and then we'll
get underway okay it's a little scary to
be leading this off I'm my expertise is
is mostly an international trade so I'm
gonna focus on that part of the braking
braking issue I guess to just list a few
of the the things that really worry us
is the World Trade Organization is being
weakened we have a trade war with China
that's disrupting supply chains u.s.
tariff revenue just hit a record of
seven billion this month now you might
say okay that's revenue but that does
point to a tax that we're paying of
about a half a percent of our GDP so
it's not trivial and I guess my main
concern over all of this is not where we
are but the worry that we sort of broke
in a kind of convention and and other
countries might sort of follow the u.s.
lead in terms of what's happening so but
somehow when I was given the opportunity
to speak here I kind of wanted to remain
optimistic and forward-looking so I
thought of the quote from Rahm Emanuel a
crisis is a terrible thing to waste and
then I looked up it's actually not from
Rahm Emanuel it's from Paul Romer that
even fit in better
he just won the Nobel Prize last year
along with our own filled in the word
house and then I wanted to talk about
building the house anyway so that was
kind of nice but anyway a crisis is a
terrible thing to waste so is there some
sense in which things are kind of torn
apart and maybe we can rebuild them in a
better way so I was trying to think of a
situation where that could be true and
that is what took me to thinking about
Bill Nordhaus because he a few years ago
in 2015 proposed something called a
climate club of a way for countries that
want to do something about climate
policy to be able to solve the
free-rider problem that's the real issue
with a global externality is to get
enough countries on board so you can
actually do something if you're just in
a non-cooperative equilibrium he has a
nice little model where it shows you can
only achieve about 12% of the the
optimal the optimal policy you should
really engage in so how does that fit in
here well when bill lord house's idea
was to make this climate club it would
be something that countries want to be
and they're not forced and they agree
mutually on a on a carbon tax that would
be higher than any of them would want to
do on their own and by so imagine in in
the models of Nordhaus how it would be a
carbon tax of about 40 to $100 per ton
of co2 which converts into somewhere 40
cents to $1 per gallon that's something
we sort of make it tangible and the idea
was that the non-member that to hold it
together in a way that hasn't wasn't
done and the Kyoto Protocol and it seems
to not be working too well with the
Paris Accord either there was going to
be a punishment of
members so they would be punished
through an import tariff now when he nor
doubts proposed this I was actually here
at the Center for study of globalization
he was presenting in front of very
distinguished people and a lot of people
pushed back as he said you know don't
mess with a system that's as wonderful
as what's happened in international
trade over years we've lowered tariffs
we've sort of solved the prisoner's
dilemma problem that all that kind of
culminating in the World Trade
Organization which is that any country
on its own actually you know as Trump's
finds out it you know you do pretty well
if you just raise a tariff it's only if
the other countries retaliate that you
get hurt so there's a kind of bad
equilibrium where everybody's raising
tariffs when we all end up with high
tariffs even though each of us thought
we were going to gain something so the
one one view of the World Trade
Organization is a kind of a solution to
that problem and when people heard Nord
House's proposal they're sort of like ah
that's kind of dangerous we're opening
up a can of worms but I guess at this
point I feel like our president has
already opened up a can of worms so
maybe we should think about the
opportunities that that gives us to
remake the system in a way that's more
amenable to through such proposals so if
to kind of conclude so in other words
try and make the best of a bad situation
when I mentioned this to a colleague he
was kind of angry with me he said you're
gonna say that World War two was good
because after that we formed lots of
good institutions well no but we're here
we I'm not saying anything about how we
got here but I'm saying what we can do
from the situation we find ourselves in
I think we find ourselves in a situation
where international institutions are
under stress the world trading system is
under stress it could get worse in
reaffirming it
let's also tweak it in a way that
more amenable to achieving really the
the the the the huge goal that we have
which is to do something about the
global do something about an effective
global climate policy so well ladies and
gentlemen I suddenly realized as I was
thinking about why my remarks for this
afternoon that it's almost exactly 25
years ago between the years of 1993 and
95 but I my colleague and political
science
Bruce Russell were working on the
problem of restoring a broken global
order can it be fixed because Yale
University and the Ford Foundation had
come together the invitation of the
United Nations secretary-general to try
to produce a report on how to get this
world in a broader better shape through
the instrumentation of international
organizations and produce a report in
time for the secretary-general to give
it to all of the members of the General
Assembly when they met in the special
session at San Francisco in June 1995
because that would be the 50th
anniversary of the founding of the
United Nations by the signing of the
Charter in June 1945 the end result is a
report which is called the United
Nations in its second half century I
think I was probably the only few words
I contributed to this report and I'm
still quite proud about that
um and what we tried to do was to deal
with a at that time pretty broken world
order they had been just after the
collapse of the Soviet Union and the
fragmentation of countries in Eastern
Europe had also been a massive outburst
of civil wars usually demographically
driven at
we've driven civil wars across Africa
the Middle East Southeast Asia the
United Nations blue helmets had gone up
tenfold from 9,000 in the field in 1991
to 90,000 in the field in the year 1993
there were 19 peacekeeping operations
the system was buckling and we were
asked if we could think of ways in which
maybe a restructured international
organization at the center of things
might help fix the world order so I'm
just gonna say a few remarks about that
effort of ours why it didn't work but
why Nautilus I'm still a little bit
optimistic about it so we went ahead
with the set of proposals which included
the following and I hope you would agree
that it makes sense we concluded that
the Security Council was his big
responsibilities just couldn't be pushed
to one side if some reformers wanted it
you had however to enhance the Security
Council by bringing in some significant
players in world affairs above all India
but perhaps also South Africa Brazil
maybe the - two of the larger
contributors of the budget like Germany
and Japan but we had to have Security
Council permanent members from the south
we had to have a better response to in
two crises of the collapse of what we
called failed States we had to persuade
the five great powers to stop using the
veto except in extraordinary cases of
threats to their own national security
rather than threatening to veto who
might be the next candidate for SiC for
Secretary General of us of the United
Nations or the veto on this or that
particular thing it it should be reduced
in size there should be a better
coordination between the United Nations
central organization and things like the
you and
P and it's organs and the World Bank and
the IMF were too drifted way apart from
the original intention which was to work
in coordination with the United Nations
rather than be totally independent
brother arrogant looking down and knows
that what these people did up in New
York while we run the world essentially
through big money pockets we produced a
nice report and gave it to the
secretary-general Boutros boutros-ghali
at the time he was in the great Rao with
Madeleine Albright so that when because
he wished to have another six year
twelve she was determined to get rid of
him and so he decided at the end not to
take our fabulous Yale University report
to San Francisco I learned quite a lot
about this in in in some the great
powers count and if you do not persuade
them and I don't well you know I concede
that persuading China and Russia at this
time would be a very difficult thing
indeed the great powers count because of
their veto the south counts and if we do
not bring them into international
organizations then it is a busted thing
what we need above all clearly is
political leadership and I see all of
you shaking your head or sighing I just
hope that in 5 to 10 years time really
we will let be at the read the bottom
end of a political leadership trough at
the moment I'm hoping it will it will
come up and we will get political
leadership but we need international
structures of far greater power and
authority and respect I hope I will see
them in my lifetime thank you I thank
you everybody for coming
fixing a broken global order so what
what is broken many things are broken
but what I want to address is the
collapse of confidence in global
institutions
and a liberal economic order free trade
order within the advanced democracies
and the what I would say about this is
that I can argue this in the book
Francis alluded to that's coming out
with Michael Kratz a principal cause of
this collapse of confidence within the
advanced democracies in the global
political and economic order is elite
complacency about insecurity within
these countries I think we have spent so
much time in the last few decades
talking about global institutions global
or transnational institutions solutions
to problems but we've forgotten an
important lesson that was told to us by
our former colleague in 1998 Jeffrey
Garret who's now Dean of the Wharton
School in a book called partisan
politics in the global economy that most
politics is really national politics and
this is I think been reiterated also by
our former another former colleague Adam
to's in his book on the financial crisis
where he gives chapter and verse of the
inability of transnational and
international institutions particularly
in the case of the eurozone crisis to
confront problems and that what has been
done more or less successfully has been
done by national governments so I think
we've we have not paid enough attention
to the role of national politics in
managing international institutions and
in managing the fallout from changes in
international institutions I said that I
think the principal cause of this loss
of confidence is elite in security elite
complacency about insecurity and I want
to emphasize that the the insecurity I'm
talking about is principally employment
insecurity in the Bureau of Labor
Statistics
release of August of this year 2019
they have been
studying the the the number of times
people have been changing jobs and
they've been looking the later baby boom
generation born between 1957 and 64 and
what you find there is those people have
changed jobs twelve point three times in
their lifetimes and if you look only a
small number of those changes is can be
accounted for like by summer jobs in
college because the great majority of
them are post at the age of twenty-two
or twenty-three so we're living in a
world in which lifetime of employment as
fundamentally vanished in these
economies and it's also a world in which
there's increasing pressure on welfare
states for demographic reasons as the
dependency ratio between the dependent
retired populations and the working age
population is squeezing government's I
think that Donald Trump whether by luck
or brilliant tactical insight understood
this insecurity and I just want to
emphasize that he understood it far
better than the people he was
campaigning against Briggs for instance
if you compare his slogan make America
great again with Hillary Clinton slogan
I campaign I'm wanna build a III believe
America's best days are ahead they're
actually both slogans of Ronald Reagan's
from the 1980s but when Reagan was
saying America's best days are in front
of us it was before we'd had people
living through three and a half decades
of wage stagnation and basically
replacing one firm one one family
incomes with two family incomes in order
to to keep treading water whereas the
the idea of make America great again
draws on what political psychologists
called loss aversion
something's been taken away from you and
I'm gonna bring it back and that was a
very different kind of message that
Trump sent and then if you look at what
Trump said in his campaigning a campaign
against Sanders for his differences with
Sanders
they agreed about the loss of jobs and
they agreed in blaming trade for that
but but for Sanders it was all about
inequality it was all about what the top
1% of getting or 0.1% are getting and
Trump never mentioned inequality not
once he said I'm gonna bring your jobs
back I mean it bring back what you what
I'm gonna get you back what's been taken
away from you he didn't even say what
Reagan said which is I want an America
in which anybody can get rich he said
I'm gonna I'm gonna get you back what
you have lost and so he keyed right on
to this insecurity now of course Trump
is offering snake oil because to the
extent job loss is about globalization
he doesn't have a strategy for getting
significant numbers of jobs back to
America and the structure of the world
economy thinks that basically impossible
he's certainly not going to do it by
subsidizing agriculture and trade Wars
and and reopening coal mines for a few
thousand people in in Pennsylvania or
wherever he's doing it so he doesn't
have a strategy for that and besides
economists debate about how much of its
really trade and how much of its
technology but he doesn't have a
strategy for the fact that most of a lot
of these jobs are now in any case going
to technology the McDonald's restaurant
that I used to have 20 workers in it
night and now has six workers in it
probably will have two workers in it
five years from now watching robots
making hamburgers and so there's again
no strategy for that either
so I think that if if we want to restore
confidence in the capacity of
governments to actually deliver in
sustaining the sorts of global
institutions that we want to see that
can address climate change that can
sustain free trade we have to really
think about what we'll enjoy what are
the policies that will address
employment insecurity and there there
are things like taking seriously the
fact that lifetime employment has gone
away it is not coming back that means we
have to revisit there used to be
programs that largely failed in the u.s.
called Trade Adjustment Assistance where
you would in the government would in
theory allow subsidized for people to to
retrain when they lost jobs to trade it
can't just be a Trade Adjustment
insistence there's got to be much more
comprehensive adjustment insurance
they've gotta have to be things like
using expansions of the Earned Income
Tax Credit this is essentially a federal
government or state government subsidy
for employment it's one of the most one
of the few genuinely redistributed
programs that is gets bipartisan support
it started in the in the Nixon
administration and has been supported by
parties on both sides of the aisle and
expanded by parties on both sides of the
aisle many times if you think about
state earned income tax credits unlike
things like minimum wage which tend to
produce races to the bottom it actually
can produce races to the top because
employers can come to different states
in search of better subsidized wages
there are other policies like lifetime
employment retraining that has to be
fine
at the national level and other things
of this General Order there's no silver
bullet but these are the sorts of things
that would address the employment
insecurity that is at the heart of what
is driving the populist politics that is
undermining the global order thank you
all for being here and I'm very feel
very honored to be flanked by some of
the most respected colleagues here at
Yale I spent most of my time studying
America's present greatest adversary
China and between switching perspectives
here and there and understanding where
the complex come from how are they
reading past each other or is it just a
simply a simple conflict of dominating
well I would have to re asked the
question of today's themes is whether it
is a broken world order or we're
witnessing a world order changing hands
now there many ways in which I think the
American public and media are quite
resistant in thinking about this
prospect but it does demand a kind of
more total picture a different kind of
world picture then I think the one that
work comes accustomed to seeing here for
instance I think we tend to still think
of the problems that China raises in
very specific silo terms whether it's an
area of science technology which that's
different from use human rights whether
it's a protest we see it also has some e
very different what the policymakers in
Beijing tend to do whereas it is very
difficult I think and challenging to
imagine just what kind of a grand
strategy that we're in some ways
confronting how should we how should we
date it of course the most readily
example and parallel that comes to mind
to many observers is the Cold War this
is China the new Russia and I think
including my colleague sitting right
next to me
had disputed this idea that such a
simple historical precedent can be
simply transplanted and but it is true
that is in during the Cold War that the
idea of an on
world order in the making was being
discussed the famous Bandung conference
at least to those who were outside of
Russia and in the US so we can think
about this world order the the early
shift of it already in the making in the
50s now I think where China comes in and
instead of make it particularly I think
challenging adversary is that it has
been a superb understudy of the Western
world order for decades if not if you
want to go with some simulation one and
a half century million one hundred fifty
years or so and it has absorbed I think
many of the rationale from not just the
US but also Singapore Japan military
strategies of course information as well
back in the 70s when China's first
opened up and there was actually kind of
goodwill between US and China at least
unofficially as you know with Nixon's
visit landmark visit China was really
nowhere near of thinking of itself
globally but that was when it understood
what it had to learn from the West it
impressed on the western side there were
several delegations academics like
ourselves so travel back and forth these
were the bridges that was supported
I think unofficially that actually even
was was still kept at a trickle in this
through the 60s that was immense good
well on both sides China wanted to
learned the West wanna to spread this
knowledge who want to collaborate and
it's really imagined that it was hard to
imagine then that just a few decades
later that it would escalate to what we
have today so what are we looking at I
think in many ways to think of China's
what kind of world picture it is
proposing it is wonder for instance is
development based rather than rule-based
right China's relationship to countries
in Africa or Southeast Asia and have
give us very different examples of where
is seeks to push where it can exert its
power and how its willing to work with
perhaps what the countries need on level
on the
call 'evil rather than what they think
should be ideologically disseminated
worldwide there's a very different kind
of strategy and I think a worldview and
when I talk to my Chinese counterparts
and actually not to not the 60 70 year
olds but for the up-and-coming their new
four-year-olds I'll explain there is a
generational gap as well and how this
picture is being played out for the 30s
and 40s who have parents who went
through in 1989 and past human cultural
revolution their parents tend to I think
share similar views as Western observers
they're very pretty cool they they put
emphasis on human rights violations
political oppression all this or the
very the very thorny issues that we're
still dealing with but for the 30s and
40s they also see a different picture
right they grew up under a one-child
policy they tend to have been given
great privilege and great resources they
tend to invest quite a bit of hope in
China as well but with clear ID they
don't see they don't idealize China as a
patriot but they do see that China is
well take a few decades will take well
into 21st century to get to where it
needs to be and it is this generation is
in some ways push towards China I think
by the kind of what's been quoted to me
as China bashing that seems to be a kind
of United strategy on the part of the
West and I think that is something to
think about are we at the same time
trying to fix or maybe trying to repair
a world order are we used to sowing
seeds for more problematic and maybe
similar replays in the future and one of
the things I would point out also that
you know China has a kind of long game
that I think is difficult for us to
think about here also because our
governance structure is very different
here every four years we're sure to see
a battle and maybe certain policies
repealed in China now there's unlimited
term on the current leadership there's a
lot of time there's at a lot of time
from their perspective to do what they
need to do we also see that
China's building immense infrastructure
around the world railroads ports
railings freeways airports the last time
that I think a country was able to
connect a whole continent through a kind
of road north-south and also cross was
basically the beginning of the American
Empire except now I think China is
actually doing it worldwide most of you
of course know about Bri and I think
even two three years ago it was often
kind of laughed off as a kind of a
vanity project or something that's more
name than substance but then lo and
behold it is essentially a world project
right it's going up into the artists
going south through Latin America
there's not a corner of the earth that
is not not in some way figure into the
Bell Road initiative plan so I think
when we think about word order I would
say a lot of it depends on how rest the
world responds that even though we think
of ourselves as sort of increasingly in
a multipolar world but our conversation
very much still evolves between
something like us and an opponent and
the strong adversary and I think that
itself is kind of misleading path I
think what is neglected is because of
the fact that we have less an existing
superpower and a contending superpower
having a faceoff at the moment that it
actually gives rester world
opportunities we might think about even
from the trade war who are the big
winners Singapore and Vietnam eight
months ago the factories in Taiwan were
ready to move into where we're looking
for warehouses move into in Vietnam so
there's a lot of more local regional
players that I think tend to be left out
of the global picture when we talk about
World Order right and I do actually
breathe that great powers matter and
great powers count but I think now
because of the uncertainty I think both
in this country but also regionally in
Asia that there's actually tremendous
opportunity that's open up for countries
like Africa in Africa or Southeast Asia
in Latin America and certainly if I were
one of those countries I would think
about how to best gain the situation
whether it's where a lot of uncertainty
a lot of room for
maneuver so I will leave it at that it's
wonderful to be here with some of the
colleagues here at Yeti for a most
admire and it's wonderful to see so many
of you coming out for the discussion
today thanks to Francis for organizing
this so I I think I'll take as my
starting point the question that is in
the toilet can it be fixed and I think
to that I have a pretty straightforward
answer it depends on whether Donald
Trump is reelected as US president next
year or not so if that happens then the
International cooperative world that
many have dreamt of bringing into being
after the Cold War and it is probably
not going to happen in our lifetime
because the institutions as we would
know from several distinguished
colleagues the institutions on which
such a World Order any kind of world
order would depend would be weakened to
the point that they cannot bear the
weight of the developments that we are
seeing a presence that's the
significance of that election so there
are lots of things happening elsewhere
in the world as well that we need to
look at that this is the one occasion in
my lifetime where it's very clear that
for Americans
the key question about what kind of
world we are going to live in in the
future can be answered here first and
foremost to to what happens in American
politics next year so I say this for two
reasons
the first one is that I believe that we
are now in a global power shift while we
are moving away from the unique polarity
in global affairs that the end of the
Cold War created so the end of the Cold
War really meant that it was only one
great power left standing and that was
the United States of America so for some
time and for quite good and if I may say
natural reasons we'll be moving away
from that I agree with yang that we are
not moving towards bipolarity so you
know what to say so China I think we are
movie
pretty force towards multipolarity so
different powers in different parts of
the world possibly on a regional basis
that are going to be more significant in
terms of how the global system of the
future is being put is being put
together this it's from my perspective
that's not necessarily bad the problem
at the moment is the speed with which
it's happening under the current
administration because if there is it is
one thing that we can learn from history
and the one who's helped us learn that
more than anyone else's is Professor
Kennedy who is here today is that power
shifts may be good or bad but first and
foremost depends on how they take place
and how quickly they take place so very
rapid power shifts have a almost
unerring legacy of ending up in
cataclysmic Wars power shifts that take
a longer period of time have at least a
chance for arrangements to be worked out
so that it's possible for the major
powers and for the rising powers to work
together at least to secure the peace if
not necessarily cooperate on a broad
scale and what the Trump administration
has done to its policies which in
reality whatever way you put it implies
a USB troll from the world it has made
our allies much more insecure it has
emboldened regimes that normally would
for good reasons have been worried about
what kind of actions their initiatives
would set off with regard to the United
States no one less concerned about it it
has sped up the very power shift that
Trump of course in his rhetoric by
saying America first has promised people
that he would stand up against so this
is something I think is really really
important to consider that the the power
shifts dynamic that we have been looking
at has sped up tremendously and I think
possibly with some quite catastrophic
results unless the United States finds a
way
or using its power selectively and and
and and in well-defined ways to try to
create a world that is more stable than
what we are looking at the moment that
won't happen under a trump presidency
whatever you think about a trump
presidency in other in other in other
directions so China of course is
particularly important illnesses as as
King pointed out but it's not a whole
story there are many other things that
are happening in terms of change that
indicates that this power transition
process has been been sped up and again
if you think about it is historically so
I mean historian by trade won't surprise
you to hear me say this that that's what
are the ways we should approach these
these issues we have to think about
parallels and analogies from the post
and as I've been arguing elsewhere to me
even though I spent a fair amount of my
career studying the Cold War it is not
the cold water and first and foremost
comes to mind when you look at how
international affairs are being
reconstituted today it is and I'm afraid
I have to say this it looks much more
like the late 19th century so the period
before World War 1 or even the interwar
era where things seem to move very
quickly in the direction of a number of
very strong nationalistic great powers
competing for power economic advantage
and influence on a global scale compared
to those systems the Cold War was
actually remarkably stable it was
dangerous first and foremost because of
the truth of of nuclear annihilation but
it had a promise built into it that both
of these powers where he had to try to
improve the world so we would argue I am
ugly and that didn't always work out for
for either of the two sides but there
was a stability to the system that we
simply didn't for in prior to 1940 9/11
priority to 1914 or or Indian table era
so that's the first reason why this
election will be so significant
that we have a power situation that is
being pushed by the very country that
has been up to now at the center of the
international system and the second one
which has been alluded to already so
I'll be quick on this is that Trump
dramatically reduces the potential on a
global scale for international
cooperation even on issues beyond
strategic conflict on issues that are
really really important such as global
health or climate change and these
issues are important in themselves I
mean they are our common future cannot
be secured without these being addressed
many people see that but what I think
fewer people see is that there is also I
spill over from these issues
increasingly to the international
situation in general so if the senses
that we cannot work together and that
United States cannot play a leadership
role in trying to deal with these acute
issues that are before us then no one
else will step up to the plate
everyone will first and foremost look
after their their own interests so in
conclusion I one of the things that I
worked on in the past is being very
critical of US foreign policy with
regard to taking on too many obligations
being too interventionist attempting to
be the world's policeman and I still
stand by that but if you compare much of
that critique from myself and others
with what is actually happening today
and particularly happening in eastern
Asia which is by far the most
significant region in terms of what is
gonna happen in the future how unstable
the situation there can easily become
because of a rapid US withdrawal then
I'm certainly on that issue on the other
side of the equation I don't think that
a United States that is seen as not
being able to handle problems dealing
with China and dealing with the East
Asian region around China is helping to
make the world more secure quite on the
contrary I think that's the region where
I dramatic power shift the power
if that happens very quickly would have
the most catastrophic results thank you
and we have some mics and so if you
would like to ask questions of the
panelists this is the time to raise your
hand
thank you thank you very much for your
for your presentation it's been very
interesting whoever I found one element
missing of your of the five
presentations of you that you made you
all talked about countries but I thought
that the element that the sovereign of
the order or the beneficiaries of the
order was missing and that is the people
in this room the Lehman's the real
people so I turn on the TV these days
and what I see are protests like see
protests everywhere I see purchase in
Ecuador protests in Chile protest in
Hong Kong for the Suniva non-partisan
Catalonia and the list could go on and
my question is what is our role there
all of the people in changing the order
can we fix do we have any role you have
any agency can we fix the order or
there's no role for us and everything is
left to the countries thank you thank
you for that comment I think it is it's
actually a great issue because we are
seeing what one of our former colleagues
here while there's time we'll call
anti-systemic movements awful for
different reasons and as a way in which
two people actually has a power that I
had not before which is the ability to
organize a bio social media is actually
technology is a huge I think one thing
that does speed up this process of
publishing is also technology
they're people who anticipate decoupled
world
I think this Kevin Kevin Rudd's platform
but also technologically you all must
anticipate that it wouldn't be
inconceivable that 2040 2050 we would
have an internet that's basically still
goes by the West American Standard and
another one that's based goes by China
and it's perfectly conceivable just be
of all this infrastructure building
right
I think in terms of world people I think
in fact what would be the random de
variable and the unknown factor is what
will happen within these countries right
on China in particular is very alarming
I mean people don't most people don't
know this but there are thousands of
protests in China
like the ones that the ones that
actually cost labor stoppage every year
and very few May across the media the
fact of ruling over such a gigantic
population this is the kind of question
of scale that we all know China is very
big as one of our colleagues at the
Financial Times you know China baked
China bad China weird you know it's one
of those three kings but scale actually
it is really hard to imagine what that
is unless you've walked through Shenzhen
or Hong Kong or Beijing and just to
think about if you're applying for
college now how many of these people you
have to compete against to get into a
place like Yale and I think for those
four for China governance first of all
within its borders is incredibly
important and I think it's because the
people have the ability to disrupt and
you will see that so the protest
movements now is not so much topple
governance is really about disruption
right enough to just be that thorn in
your side and they're also they also
coalesce around different causes you
might also notice that and it's not that
the people have one particular grievance
but they all find a way to come together
for that movement so I think it is I
think the people without sounding
Marxism betraying my undergraduate
background at Berkeley I think that is
key that is the unaccounted for and
that's still hopeful factor well I'll
just say briefly that I think that
people can spontaneously have much
sustained effect in politics that
there's a reason we have political
parties and political institutions and
unfortunately what's gone on over the
last four decades this is really
alluding to my book last year with
Francis on responsible parties but
what's happened is as people have felt
increasingly out of control of their
futures and as people have experienced
the insecurities that I was talking
about in my earlier remarks one dominant
response across much of the developed
world has been to dim to basically
weaken political parties to do
and more direct control in the in the
decision makings or referendums and
plebiscites brexit and so forth
to get more and more grassroots control
of political decision-making within
parties and in the selection of
candidates through primaries direct
election of party leaders and so forth
and the the results of all of this is to
make it decreasing leafy's decreasing li
possible for governments to govern they
are hamstrung even in countries like
Germany that used to have very strong
political parties you see now it takes
seven months to form a government that
has to be approved at the grassroots
level by the four hundred and fifty
thousand members of the SPD and so what
what you get is a world in which
governments can't govern and then people
feel even more disempowered and
alienated that by the fact that they
can't govern and that leads to demand
demands for more local control so I
think that the the real answer is just
to strengthen parties so that they can
deliver the things that people want
rather than engage in this cycle of
weakening the capacity of governments to
govern
supposing every one of those protests in
all of those countries led actually to
the governments in all of those
countries being responsible Democratic
aware of global challenges parliamentary
governments then the link would have
been made between what's happening on
the street there and those governments
being able to work with other
governments to actually get things done
in
I organized and agreed way through
organizations which we have I've made
the point earlier that I don't think
we're going to get this global this
broken global order fixed until
responsible government's step in and do
that in various levels whereas
socio-economic or environmental Accords
or dealing with breakdown of law and
order and trans-border mayhem but it has
to be government's but I'm rather
hopeful it's sometimes these protests
lead to governments which are reformist
governments why shouldn't they be hi
thank you really really interesting
discussion and and talk so thank you
very much my question was I wondered if
you could comment on global population
size and structure and my question has
two main parts the first part is to what
extent would you say the current
brokenness of the world order is due to
global overpopulation and then secondly
if we are in fact looking at creation of
a new world order with China at the fore
rather than a broken order would you say
the difference in population structure
between China and the USA would be a
major driver of that handover so I I do
think it's true that demographic
increase has driven some of the resource
resource diced and distributary issues
that's behind what the inverse oppose
was talking about earlier on but I do
think we are at a tipping point with
regard which will go to this as you know
we are both with regard to world
population growth overall what is now
turning towards a more downloads trend
but maybe especially if we look at the
relationship between the powers that
he's assumed her her
to have the greatest influence in the
future so I believe that the
unprecedented decline in in the number
of Chinese are particularly young
Chinese those who will be working and
staffing Model T the factory so for that
you know that's how the minute the
military enterprises I am agraphia
decline in terms of the number of young
people the equal of which in relative
terms the world has never seen before is
going to have a very strong impact on on
what happens in it would happen so
demographic change of course take some
whisper so implicitly a generation to to
be seen but in in a generation I think
this is going to be really significant
there's one of the reasons why I am
saying that I'm pretty sure we are not
heading towards bipolarity that yeah I
think towards multipolarity because one
of the things that a country in the
future will need to have in order to
sustain itself and make its mark
internationally is a healthy demographic
profile and fewer and fewer countries
outside of Africa have a healthy
demographic profile because I mean China
is an in a position all all by itself
for reasons that are mainly
self-inflicted the wall child the
one-child policy but you see similar
trends in Europe and you see them
increasingly I think in other in other
parts of the world as well where this
will lead we don't know I mean what I'm
pretty sure of is a world that is
getting rapidly older will not be a
world that will necessarily be better
suited for dealing with the kind of
problems that we are talking about on
the on a global scale and I think the
countries that are at the forefront of
that demographic term towards older
populations will probably be the ones
that are less capable of contributing
you have something you want to say about
demography boy what a question took all
of world history to 1875 to get a
population of 1 billion on this planet
by 1925 50 years it was 2 billion by
1975 it was 4 billion by the year 2000
it had just crested 6 billion it's now
seven point eight seven point nine
billion the best estimates of the UN
Population Fund or something like nine
point five billion people on this planet
by the roundabout 2040 ninety percent of
the increase of that coming
in Africa the aging is another phenomena
and then there's a question of whether
we really do want ladies and gentlemen
all of the 9.5 billion
to be raised up to the level of Kansas
which is what that Senator said famously
in the middle of the Second World War he
looked forward to the time when
everybody in the world will be raised up
to the level of Kansas that is to say
with the GDP per capita of something
like $35,000 which would mean that the
world was utterly devastated in resource
and climatic terms the dilemmas of this
population issue and the way in which it
will break through from time to time
sometimes beyond beyond beyond ways in
which I can I I can't think through all
of the consequences of that except that
I think that to ignore the demographic
push in world affairs over the next 10
or 25 years and to think that we should
be concentrating only on the atomic
asyou are only on the traders you are
only on technology is you're only
what to do with the big four means that
we would there's some bigger thing
happening involving most of the planet
professor Kennedy actually all but
especially professor Kennedy professor
jinx when Professor westerly had all
discussed us-china relations in
particular one of the comments was that
correctly I I think that Trump has
played a key role in a worsening of
us-china relations and sort of led to a
worsened u.s. role in the world but at
the same time in Washington DC there
appears to be a bipartisan consensus on
having adopting a tougher stance towards
China and scaling back on America's
armed commitments abroad so my question
then is do you think this changing
worsening us-china relations and a
reduced America's role in the world do
you think that is contingent upon the
policies pursued by the next
administration or do you think that
would that is likely to happen
irrespective of the administration that
comes next we have two great China
experts on his panel just along there
well he always leaves the most difficult
questions to me so I think I mean the
current predicament as I try to have the
loin in my opening remarks it's very
much in in your in your question right
now I think so this administration has
certainly on trade rules who knows some
strategic issues a more confrontational
approach to China that with previous
administrations have had but that's
happening at the same time as the very
same administration seems to be very Pro
pointed in a deliberate way with
reducing the u.s. overall influence in
eastern Asia by having falling out with
with with long-term allies with building
down the links to newer friends of the
United States Indonesia Vietnam India
and and in general signaling to the
leaders in Beijing that we're going to
confront you
by all means that won't cost us a thing
as long if you can sit back here you do
well out of the tariff so some
assumption we we will be number one you
know that's not how world power works
and and this is the reason why I am why
I'm I'm worried so I think you're right
in saying that even if we get a new
administration in place of the next full
I do think there will be significant
tensions in the us-china relationship I
mean some of this has to do with a
structural aspect of things right I mean
you're dealing with one established
great power sees itself as certainly the
number one power in the world United
States in and the rising power that is
seen as a challenger to this this
hegemon or whatever where one should
understand United States the tensions
come also that's quite it's quite it's
quite understandable that different in
character the different in area that
different in history and background
the big question is how can one handle
those kinds of issues and this is what
I'm afraid of
so I think that this idea of a decrease
in American commitments to deal with
other countries in Asia which for which
in many ways are themselves rising and
not is rising in terms of what they see
as their own drone potential power and
influence that that would destabilize
the region much more than what I
continued even it's not a scaled-down
level American presence would lead so
that's what my hope after the next
election here that we get an
administration that looks pretty cool
code auditors but there will be tensions
and conflicts between the United States
and China as there will be between the
United States and other countries not
least on trade issues but that's not a
reason to forego an order that has been
able for a very long time to keep the
peace in Asia that's my view well you
need something to rebuild bipartisanship
on so I think regardless so that I
suppose that as good as any and it's
absolutely true I think that you know
China's rise to power would not have
been possible without America's
simultaneous retreat from the world
stage I think that's very very clear but
I think from China's perspective
regardless of what the next
administration is like is not going to
change his plans too much I think for
many years now for at least several
years it's clear that United States is
an important a very important but not a
decisive factor for China and you can
see that China has been building
essentially a containment strategy by
essentially building out into the world
so that it can use it as a way of
buffering whatever is happening with
let's say with the trade wall you can
see that it just moves elsewhere Huawei
expand while hallway is building these
high-tech cities in Ethiopia Kenya etc
it is basic bankrolling them giving them
almost equivalent foreign aid so I think
it's very clear that China has built a
kind of Network and global
infrastructure where it's kind of like a
kind like a spiderweb it's like if once
Isis plucked is the it can it can be
pressure can echo elsewhere so it has
been building that kind of nimble
capacity worldwide I think so that so
that it would not be beholden to any
particular one power and what am I do so
several of you recently spoke about the
the need to empower people or make
government more accountable to to the
people and professor West at you
suggested that you think we're returning
to or that the future will most resemble
the multipolar era of the period between
nineteen nineteen hundred and nineteen
and forty-five of course it separately
no I'm sure that this period was one in
which leaders used public opinion to
justify either
inaction and foreign policy or
aggressive expansionist policies are you
concerned that increasing popular
empowerment in this century may have
similar effects and if so how might
those dangers be tempered yes I think
that the the the the idea that popular
empowerment is a solution to the problem
you had a so popular empowerment at the
expense of what and if it's the expense
of political parties that can actually
govern then it's going to exacerbate the
danger and I agree with RNA that the
parallels to to the pre-world War one
and interwar period are are the most
striking parallels that's it is it's
also an ear or was those particularly
the interwar period was era of growing
employment insecurity and many of the
established democracies it was a period
of great party fragmentation in the
european systems which were also seeing
now and it was appeared
which demagogues mobilized populist
opinion against existing party systems
and and so I do think that the the
solution is not a lot of sub popular
empowerment but rather the empowerment
of parties that can actually govern just
at one footnote I think you know power
empowerment's are great but you have so
also realized why now we have a very big
issue with being empowered on the wrong
kind of information right I mean
misinformation can fan popular actions
in ways are very frightening or you
think at the the violence in Southeast
Asia I think that's it's it's it's also
about you know what kind of because they
used to be popping up rising you have
you have a goal you know what your
ideology is you know that well they get
you know where each other stand but
these days it's very difficult and
popular opinions are themselves being
swayed one way or the other right
we know that for certain something very
alarming obviously some of this goes
back to again we'll put in register at
the beginning so you know you can
understand where this reaction comes
from I mean it's a reaction against what
could be seen as failing state capacity
to act for you to act for the the
individuals who particularly in this
country who feel that having won the
Cold War having gone through all the
changes that enormous changes that are
taking place in terms of the economy of
this country's instant which are often
not you know commented on enough how
this country has gone from making things
to to becoming a center for financial
capital and a center for high-tech
development which it which is you know
made life really difficult for people
who were connected to to the productive
economy that this country stood for for
a very long time
and and within less than a generation it
has gone from United States has gone
from being the world's largest capital
exporter to becoming the world's largest
rapidly important of course this has
consequences for people's daily lives
and and in particular I think this is
visible here now because unlike
other powers that have experienced what
you could call relative decline over a
period of time there is almost no social
safety net for the people who have been
hurt as a result of this readjustment in
the in the u.s. in the u.s. position you
know a lot of bad things could be said
about British decline in the mid mid
19th century mid 20th century but where
at least for a while there were
institutions in place that correctly
look off to some of the people who were
the worst hurt by this kind of
development you do not get that here and
I think in order to understand the
reaction that we've got now in American
politics one has to understand that
perhaps more than understanding is the
International
could I just add since you brought up
Britain in in the earlier part of the
20th century it's it's a note it's
notable they had much stronger political
parties and and in Britain in the 1930s
there were there were fascists as well
the Mosley i'ts for example had more
members in 1936 than the Nazi Party had
in Germany but because they had two
strong political parties they couldn't
get a foothold in Parliament so if if we
could go back to the discussion between
China and the US and that kind of
relative positions on the world stage
maybe I'm misreading your narrative a
little bit but it seemed to me that
China has been biding its time for quite
a keeping a low international profile
but that has now changed and it is like
with the belt and Road initiative is
like their typical example it is trying
to take more of a leadership role
internationally and as we've discussed
the u.s. is stepping back and that there
is an appetite within the u.s. to
withdraw some support from the UN
withdraw from its kind of more
expansionist military or
interventionalists kind of behavior that
has been as the global hegemon doing
over the last few decades and so to me
that doesn't seem like
recipe for a clash it seems like as one
retreats the other maybe steps in let me
do you so but presumably there will be
sticking points and where do you think
those would be like is it the cultural
hegemony that is where America will
suddenly feel like that the relationship
will become inflamed or is it military
you know expansionism or is it where
democracy is no longer being portrayed
as like the global ideal so I guess and
I guess one further point is that as the
u.s. maybe puts down some of these
leadership of international institutions
do you see that China may try and pick
up that leadership role but maybe in
more of a bilateral sense not within the
structures of the UN for example that
we've seen up to this point those
institutions have been well underway
right the Asia infrastructure
development investment bank their Silk
Road Fund and I think you're absolutely
right that just in the past I think
couple of years you know the the keeping
low just want harmony taina rhetoric
really changed one of the very clear
instances is you know maybe 18 months
ago or there was this group of
scientists under Chinese county
scientists who specialize in Tibetan
Plateau
Himalayan plateau and they put forth
this argument that they're the third
pole that to say North Pole South Pole
and then there's a third Pole because
they share certain climactic you know
some of my similar biomass issues etc
etc and the reason that came up with
that is because China wants to be an
acetal table at the Arctic why the
Arctic
you know the Arctic's been melting in
some ways a faster than the rest of the
world and with a through waterway the
shipping time that it takes to go from
Norfolk are up to Asia will be reduced
by a third if you go that route reduced
by 1/3 that is quite significant and you
can dodge the tax ruin or the poll tax
you have to pay the suez canal and you
know malacca if you look at this marine
you know bringing map in real-time it's
always congested so this is actually
very very important and a kind of a real
I don't want over use that would be a
real game-changer I think Google for
global trade and also oil tankers and
their cetera cetera so for China they
built they were very you know very very
cautiously trying to play nice and this
is just a science exploration and this
has really changed in the past six
months or eight months and it's now much
more aggressive it really thinks that it
has a role to play in the Arctic it's
it's it's changing and this this type of
Redax are changing everywhere in this
reach and i think in part is in response
to us because that the clashes been so
great that it decides it's it's that if
you listen if you read you know what's
reported in chinese media it really is
this very incendiary but very hurt kind
of rhetoric that recalls of course a
central humiliation so and so forth but
it is kind of a long process i think a
lot of times we think about you know
china us is really about what's
happening now like it's never happened
before but so it occurs to me counting
that two of the five experts of here are
China experts and four of the seven
questions posed by the audience somehow
to do with China and China and the
United States so regardless of this I
don't particularly there is something
else going on in one's national
sentiments and national apprehensions
and it is what Allah was talking about a
little bit before is under the very good
question here but whether a change of
administration in this country or a
change of administration on the Chinese
side would make
much difference if there is just a
long-term secular shift in the global
economic balances if it was the case of
some economists I'd love to have some
now come in on this if it was the case
that he's and gentlemen that our
American GDP would grow roughly to 2.25
percent per annum over the next 10 20 30
years and the Chinese GP would grow not
at the rate it's been doing in the past
30 or 40 years but it just grew at four
and a half percent to 5 percent a year
then that simply means that there is a
huge secular shift regardless of who is
in government and one side of the
Pacific Ocean
or on the other side and this strikes me
that now I I feel I'm back in some sort
of echo way where we were about 35 years
ago where every every event I came to
about international affairs here was
about Japan under the Japanese red and
the Japanese challenge and the Japanese
buying Rockefeller Plaza and I was
switched but I think and I like the
comments of the three of you um I think
that it's a bigger shift it's a much
much bigger shift than any perceived and
as we saw short-term rise of Japan to
challenge the American position in the
world well I just wanted to start with
something trivial which is with those
different growth rates yet all China's
gonna double relative to the US and
around 30 years so that's a pretty big
change and I guess
but the problem is I guess in in our
economics way of thinking we wouldn't
put so much weight on just the pure
solid I think the political and
international relations part where I
feel not out of my out of my league if
that matters but just for the pure
economics of it I'm not so sure that's
such an important issue and I mean I
guess I kind of wonder also about the
you know the watching brought up about
the going through the Arctic and so on
it's very intriguing and yet I think
that's not gonna be first order for what
China is I mean you know I was just
looking at China's exports to the US
have fallen 20% in one year I doubt that
going through the Arctic is gonna really
be of that magnitude and somehow they're
they're living through that so one more
thing I guess while I'm have the mic is
thinking on that last question that
Francis asked me to respond to and I was
a little slow one thing I recently was
looking at about the decline of
manufacturing and RNA brought that up
about and it's certainly true but it's
just steady it's just a perfect line of
the fraction of US workers in
manufacturing sector from 1950 to about
a to the Great Recession just straight
as an arrow so why is it suddenly right
at the end of that so the rate of change
it's a it couldn't go on like that
forever it it'd go - and now it's kind
of flattened out but but why all the
sudden was that so disruptive a I
believe it could be but I think there's
a big question there about why now and
maybe so maybe it's just a sort of thing
always an irritant that interacted with
other thing
so I guess I'm not so sure of it being
the causal or at least not the one
causal factor Wow yeah I think well if
we think about
I mean we're moving to I I do feel a lot
of these trends are not all bad I mean
if we're a bunch of old people will all
be docile II sitting around if we're
young taking care of old people and if
we're old being taken care of and
probably won't be as much conflict
well it'll be it'll be at a smaller
scale the conflict gets and but what we
owe and and of course we're moving I
mean I think a big issue to kind of tie
back into the China issue is that we're
kind of moving into a world of
everything being intangible and so I
think that's a big part of this China
issue is the property rights over
intangibles and I do feel that that
that's where you know the administration
has something of a point I don't know if
that's that maybe I kind of cover for
something else but that's where there's
a sort of logic to their irritation with
China I think is that we probably do
need to be a world that respects
property rights over over intangibles if
we're going to kind of move into a world
where we don't have so much
manufacturing and everything sort of is
anybody an expert on that 5g anyone I
know all right I wanted to jump in on
this there was a hand
there and there's a hand this is just on
the lining Sam's question about why now
which i think is a really really
important question because you know
these have been trends have been going
on for a long time and of course what
happened in 2008 2009 accentuated much
of this but almost confessed that that
is I think one of the most important
issues to try to figure out I mean the
only part of the answer I think we know
and I am talking about situation in the
United States is that a certain kind of
manufacturing jobs was probably
declining more quickly even before the
Great Recession to cold and in other
parts of the manufacturing sector and
it's possible that it's that in social
terms that are unleashed you know this
tremendous political anger in terms of
our over over an overall process that
has been going on for much longer that's
not much of an answer but it's a really
really important question and it's a
question that again brings echoes of
earlier historical periods so why do
long-term trends that people would see
as negative suddenly lead to a deep
fundamental distrust of institutions and
abilities we're going to adjourn to the
upstairs reception and the conversation
can continue but just to say let's get
the last few questions maybe keep your
comments and questions just quickly
we've spent most of this time and we
haven't really mentioned the European
Union where do you see do you see it as
becoming a mediator between the US and
China do you see it asserting itself and
and you know kind of becoming a
three-part power structure or you see it
becoming utterly irrelevant and
splintering and you know facing both
pressures
well I think you know in 2006 we saw the
publication of Tony Judds book post war
shortly before he died and one of the
many themes in that book was that the EU
has always been an elite project and the
first time it hits a real challenge it
look out and he was certainly right
about that and I am just to come back to
to the twos book it you know it's a it's
a really stunning documentation of the
inability of the of the EU to coordinate
any kind of response to eurozone crisis
for years and years and years and it it
certainly seems to be an open question
whether the EU is consolidating or D
consolidating at this point so I I
wouldn't I wouldn't buy a lot of stock
in the idea that they will be mediating
much thank you I will question for
professor Kennedy and you made a
comparison of Japan 35 years ago to
China today and I wonder if we can we
can put the two countries together
because in 2015 the Prime Minister of
Australia
he told Angela Merkel German Chancellor
that two feelings jo-jo our relationship
with China
why is greedy why is a fear that means
China now make give people the feeling
of a fear I want to know Japan
20 35 years ago winter when Japan was
trying to buy the world did people have
the feeling of a fear because we honest
we understand the why today
China gives the people the feeling of a
fear because it has no row of law and no
separation power and the press
remain our place and whose end of his
day so can we make the Clarisse
can we make the same the same statement
with Japan 35 years ago and the China
today thank you thank you
very pertinent question ladies and
gentlemen about whether the fear of
Japan which many of you in this audience
remember the Japanese challenge the
penetration of the world economic order
the the unfairness the imbalance as
saira in some ways leading to Sean
Connery movies leading to a belief at
this this was something that we find
very hard to handle was outrageous that
we defeated them in the second world war
now they were coming and getting us in a
insidious way could this is this is that
set of sentiments of fear and worry now
repeating itself with regard to China
but I would say yes in many parts of the
country it is there is it China on the
brain phenomenon across United States
just as there was a Japan on the brain
phenomenon you did not ask me whether I
think the fear is valid so I'm going to
duck that particular question but I
think that to to watch what's happening
is it's clear that it is very very
similar indeed said fear
but I just my memory is that a words
like greed and words like cunningness
and words like deviousness and words
like unfair competition were commonplace
35 years ago in regard to Japan as they
are now widespread in this country about
about China I I think there actually is
a critical difference China is trying to
build food water Navy and this actually
goes back to the Arctic why that's
important and the remilitarization I
think we have not seen escalation like
this we have not even touched on thank
you for bringing that up not quite not
the kind of focus China's not just an
economic threat right is trying to you
know it is going for a one bundle
package deal where actually tries to
dominate on every front I think very
very brief question I don't know how
brief this is can you hear me I don't
know how brief this is but who are we
fixing the world for 500 years of
Western capitalism has created a few
inequities are those going to be
addressed in the next few years
[Laughter]
well you have no idea of the nature of
the world's inequities in the year 1500
[Laughter]
we're just add something to that
although inequality within countries has
grown massively global inequality has
not in fact it's declined in the and if
you look at the number of people have
pulled being pulled out of poverty
globally in the last 40 years it's
actually not a depressing story and it
might be if you want a happy a note on
which to end maybe that's it yeah and
that's also a China story
[Applause]
[Music]